so sort of five five things connected so
four
I remain this makes me feel positive and
optimistic about the positive program of
naturalism I'm very confident about its
legs to carry on among intellectuals and
in a pot as a positive program and what
I mean by the positive program I mean at
least as committed to more than just the
denial of supernaturalism in the realm
of knowledge growth in production but
actually as a program that basically is
is comfortable with the idea that what
there is and all there is is natural and
that and and in some ways maybe not in a
self-centered way but the idea that
maybe we're smart enough to keep
figuring out the secrets of nature
second thing though I'm still nervous
I'm as nervous as I was before I came in
about the prospects for naturalism in
the wider culture I just think that it's
nice to be in a place like this among
like-minded people but I still think the
that whether or not the wider culture
will come around is a completely open
question and I get nervous about it but
number three I think a key that came out
at this conference to whether or not the
prospects for naturalism are on the
positive side or negative side depends
upon whether we can find secular
communities for secular meaning mosques
of mattering something like that to be
ecumenical
so that we're not Bowling Alone I mean
and I think we I think what kitten de
came out nicely is that we take this
problem you know seriously some more
than others
the fourth thing is and this this
relates to something Alex said maybe I'm
accentuating the positive this is my
nature
the half-full aspect I was happy but
maybe was under disgust I was happy that
the kind of naturalism that I thought
was discussed here was not reductive and
was not a limit of this and was happy
with naturalistic emergence I guess I
would put it that way coming in we're
comfortable with talking about levels
and emergent phenomena but I I think
that what alex is way of putting it was
under disgust so we're not I'm not
positive
you know yeah and and finally this goes
back to something
Massimo said my view was strongly
confirmed that although almost
everything I think Dan says about if you
were going to give a positive view of
free will this is what it should look
like it should be a compatible inception
I think that what Jerry and then the
discussion that he helped us have shows
that the concept of free will is so
contested so embedded in several
different traditions that it would be
better if we just said we're not going
to talk about that anymore
I mean I took this position in writing
in 2000 and the problem of the so I just
said it is a philosophical black hole
and it sucks in all smart people and
then we don't come out and there's no
light jet so I do think that that
switching up the conversation saying
that has too many connotations there's
these contested meanings
we'll go back to what Aristotle said
let's talk about voluntary and
involuntary let's talk about when John
Dewey says I gave this quote today and I
think many many years ago from Dewey Jay
he says what men and women have fought
for in the name of freedom has never
been metaphysical freedom of the will
it's always been political freedom
social freedom
and then secondly I think on the
freewill topic the Devils in the details
and I very much agree with what Terry is
said following up on the comment about
criminal justice which is so helpful you
know we're gonna figure this out it's we
can't be this is part of the
naturalistic program I mean we're we're
here now it's a long long program it'll
take for as long as we're around we'll
figure out the different causes of human
behavior and then we're gonna have to
make wise judgments about which causes
we think are exculpatory and which ones
are not and and we are going to have to
take into account what Simon said too is
we may over rate the and ascribe moral
worth or lack of worth to events too
much based on the more the more the
conscious proximate causes and it just
may be that as we understand the whole
system better we'll have a better view
about human action and that will change
I think our conception about moral
morality in the law but that's a long
way down the road I have nothing
enlightening to say except wait and see
thank you
you